[Musica]
l'industria del futuro avrà solo due
dipendenti uomo e un cane
il compito dell'uomo sarà quello di
nutrire il cane e il compito del cane
sarà quello di controllare che l'uomo
non tocchi nulla questa frase di warren
denis ci dice due cose datore bene sei
un saggista americano che si occupa di
organizzazione aziendale che ci dice che
l'uomo non avrà un ruolo all'interno del
sistema produttivo del futuro ma ci dice
anche un'altra cosa il suo intervento
sarebbe lesivo e quindi abbiamo bisogno
di qualcuno che controlli che l'uomo non
tocchi nulla
un cane ora in venice però non è l'unico
a ritenere che il futuro nel futuro
l'uomo non avrà un ruolo determinante
nel sistema produttivo
barack obama ha lasciato un report suo
predecessore in cui ha sottolineato il
rischio che porta con sé
l'automatizzazione e questo rischio è la
perdita di milioni di posti di lavoro
io non mi occupo di produzione lavoro
per un'azienda che non fa beni non
produce cose ma da servizi servizi di
logistica e di trasporto e mi sono
chiesto se qualcosa del genere possa
succedere anche all'interno del mio
settore di riferimento
un settore nel quale per la verità non
succede mai nulla
mi sono chiesto quale fosse stata
l'ultima disruptive innovation del mio
settore quindi qualcosa che ha cambiato
ha stravolto le regole del gioco e sono
dovuto andare indietro fino al 1850 al
motore a scoppio ma però mi occupo di
innovazione quindi non posso guardare
indietro devo guardare avanti scoprendo
che quello che sta arrivando è
radicalmente diverso la guida autonoma è
la cosa più famosa il camion che va da
solo ma in realtà la lista delle
innovazioni è davvero molto molto lunga
si parla di carburanti alternativi dal
gas naturale liquido il cammino
elettrici soluzioni aiuti physical
internet intelligenza artificiale
applicata ai magazzini e quindi come ci
dobbiamo preparare a questo cambiamento
cosa succederà bene io adotto un
approccio che mi sento mia nonna lo
aspettavate einstein mia non siano
andate leone mi dice per prepararti a un
cambiamento pensa sempre al peggio mia
nonna è ottimista si chiama che
tranquilla di nome bruno e comunque
questa è il suo consiglio
e così ho fatto ho immaginato una catena
logistica iper semplificata e ciò
appiccicato alcune di queste innovazioni
quello che succede oggi è che un
responsabile acquisti un bayern
definisce alcuni servizi logistici che
desidera comprare se mette in relazione
con un commerciale lato operatore
logistico e concordano un prezzo
dopodiché la merce passa all'interno di
un magazzino nel momento in cui viene
ricevuto un ordine da parte vostra
la merce viene caricata su un camion su
un altro mezzo e parte questi autisti
poi sono coordinati da una persona che
nel settore si chiama disponente ebbene
in futuro potremmo pensare che non ci
sara piu responsabile acquisti perché
esistono sistemi haiti in grado di
elaborare automaticamente una domanda di
servizi ma non ci sarà neanche un
commerciale perché un sistema i team
software potrà mettersi in contatto con
un sistema di pricing automation molto
sofisticato e che gli potrà
automaticamente dare un prezzo per il
servizio che richiede ma siamo poi
all'interno di un magazzino nel quale
sarà tutto robotizzato e anche la testa
del magazzino sarà robotizzata ci
saranno intelligenza artificiale che
potrà calcolare anche maniera predittiva
grazie alla gestione di big data
dove andrà la merce come
come dovrà essere gestita ecco quindi
che nel momento in cui arriverà un
ordine neanche più da parte vostra ma da
parte del vostro frigorifero che
deciderà che al momento di comprare il
formaggio latte il succo di frutta
partirà l'ordine attraverso una
piattaforma di ecommerce che dirà
l'intelligenza artificiale del magazzino
che il vostro frigorifero vuole qualcosa
verrà caricato su un camion a guida
autonoma quindi senza un autista che non
avrà quindi la necessità di essere
coordinato da nessuno indicativamente vi
chiederei aiuto per contare alle persone
che lavorano all'interno di questa
catena logistica
che non sono esattamente 0 ma bensì
si tratta di un uomo e un cane ora non è
che questa prospettiva mi lasci
esattamente tranquillo è più o meno
questo stato d'animo ma credo che sia
anche il vostro stato d'animo e la mia
domanda è succederà davvero secondo mia
nonna chiaramente sì succederà davvero
sarà un casino ma succederà veramente in
realtà non ne ho la minima idea deve
spettare la risposta non lo soffrono
mente e non credo che nessuno ve l'ha
possa dare una risposta per ogni esperto
che vi dice che questo sarà il futuro
ve ne sono tanti altri che vi dicono che
non sarà mai così che la macchina non
prenderà mai il posto dell'uomo è che
per ogni posto di lavoro che verrà perso
ve ne sara un altro a prendere a
prendere il suo posto
però vorrei comunque soffermarmi su
quella che istintivamente percepiamo
come prospettiva peggiore e non potrebbe
essere altrimenti perché in questa
prospettiva in questo mondo in cui non
ci sarà lavoro o non ci sarà lavoro per
tutti il messaggio è semplice la
centralità del lavoro verrà meno il
lavoro importantissimo
al lavoro ci passiamo 8 9 10 ore al
giorno se non ci passassimo così tanto
tempo non sapremmo come mantenere nuove
le nostre famiglie
cerchiamo la realizzazione personale
attraverso il lavoro molto spesso
giudichiamo noi stessi giudichiamo gli
altri attraverso il lavoro ma è ancora
di più il lavoro è il fondamento dello
stato
siamo una repubblica fondata sul lavoro
e quindi e quindi cosa dobbiamo fare in
un mondo in cui non c'è lavoro possiamo
porci il problema di come creare
generare nuovi posti di lavoro oppure
faccio una domanda ancora più difficile
e chiederci quale sarà il fondamento
della nostra vita se non più il lavoro
dal trap
parte non siamo venuti al mondo per
lavorare e per comprare ma molto
banalmente per vivere
e allora mondo in cui i beni e servizi
saranno resi disponibili disponibili
non mi sembra davvero così terribile
certamente presenta delle minacce ma
anche tante opportunità e l'opportunità
maggiore è che se mai ci sarà questa
rivoluzione saremo noi a farla per cui
possiamo decidere come la vogliamo
e io questa domanda me la sono fatta
ebbene io vorrei che il lavoro non fosse
più un'esigenza ma una scelta
vorrei che gli unici lavori realmente
necessari fossero quelli legati alla
cura della persona ea l'ingegno e la
creatività
vorrei che la mia competitività e la
competitività delle aziende all'interno
delle quali lavoriamo non si misurasse
sul sacrificio ma sulla fantasia e
ancora di più
vorrei che il fulcro delle nostre vite
non fosse il lavoro ma la cura del tempo
come quella che c'è qui in cui sono con
talia e la mia nipotina a ginevra
ecco vista così questa rivoluzione non
mi fa più così tanta paura e la
rivoluzione che vorrei
[Applauso]
cazzo